[Music]
from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills
polls are coming in across the country
right now but it's too
soon to tell how votes will shake out in
pivotal
swing states right now we are seeing
that biden is at 131 electoral votes
and trump is at 98. trump went into
election day hoping for a surge of
in-person voters as republicans are
overwhelmingly more likely to vote in
person
but over 100 million people voted early
so the question
is whether those voters will go for
biden and more importantly whether those
voters will go for him
in those pivotal battleground states we
will be waiting for some time for the
results from swing states particularly
pennsylvania a state where mail-in
ballots couldn't be counted until today
in exit polls one thing that's
interesting is that biden is doing well
with third-party voters which
was not the case for hillary clinton in
2016 so that could
impact how he performs in those
battleground states
florida is currently at 93 percent with
trump up by three points
biden is showing strength in north
carolina and again we should be getting
results from
arizona in the next hour or so
looking past the presidential election
we are seeing some results from senate
races across the u.s
john hickenlooper's win in colorado
represents the first senate seat to flip
to democrats tonight
but also the alabama senate flipped and
republicans took
back a senate seat there and this comes
as we're watching several other senate
senate races to see whether congress
could flip to blue
now one issue that was really on the
hearts and minds of voters heading into
the ballot box today
was of course coven 19 and we're joined
by a voter this evening who survived
coronavirus
to talk with him about how his
experience with the virus impacted his
vote
the current administration's response to
the pandemic and my own
family's experience with covet
has only cemented my resolve to
participate politically
it's been a long slow arduous process
to recovery but one that we attack every
day
with a lot of gratitude for the result
because it hasn't turned out that way
for over 175
000 other families and that's not
something that we
take lightly whatsoever
i did not vote in 2016 which was by no
means unique
among my demographic and age group but
it is a decision that i
quickly regretted and have come to
more in the past four years as the
current leadership has affected me
in my family more and more intimately
around the end of march different
members of my family started feeling
unwell with symptoms that were
consistent with the virus
and my dad it hit him hardest
and he just never really turned the
corner and got better
he was prescribed hydroxychloroquine
after starting to take that drug
he didn't sleep for three days in a row
his heart was racing
he had shortness of breath by the fourth
day
we were rushing him to the hospital and
he was having a heart attack
we think it was in large part due to the
prescription and application of that
[Music]
drug
he remained in icu for almost the entire
month of april
during which my mom sisters and i lived
phone called a phone call
checking in with his nurses and doctors
what ended up
doing the trick for my dad was a plasma
exchange
they basically recycled his plasma with
with fresh plasma it wasn't plasma with
somebody with antibodies so he managed
to come home
around the end of april and since then
has been going to physical therapy every
day
in which he's essentially had to learn
how to walk again
every physical function atrophied while
he was in bed for a month
the thing that's lost on the general
public as it relates to the virus
is that as a survivor
most of my trauma is physical i'm trying
to pick up the pieces of
who i was physically our son grant my
wife kelly and our daughters chandler
and cameron experienced
the emotional trauma of
almost losing me several times it was
incredibly difficult to watch press
conferences every day
the front line workers many many are
taking it
i happen to be taking it i happen to be
taking it
right directly i'm taking it hydroxide
right now yeah we had to sit and watch
that
him talk about the drug that might have
killed my father
in that sort of offhand manner
my situation was more dire than we can
even articulate
and it's caused us as a family to
fight through that emotion together but
it's also caused us to look at
our country and the world in a much
different way
in 2016 a big reason that i didn't vote
was because of my skepticism over how
how much big government matters and how
much it affects
me it's never been clear how much big
government does matter how much
competent leadership from the top down
can be at times of life or death
importance
i don't think that the virus was a
political agenda but it certainly has
been
politicized it's difficult to have
a positive perspective toward the
decisions that this administration made
and grant is joining us live now to talk
about his experience voting today
grant thank you so much for making time
to chat with us first
i just want to ask how are you and your
family holding up how are you doing
we're doing really well thank you for
asking i'm actually not living with them
anymore they're still in
the atlanta area but i recently moved up
to dc
um but i'm still checking in with them
as much as possible every day
my dad is still steady in his recovery
at
in physical therapy every day and um
again we're still very grateful for the
result
um of that whole that whole experience
um but we
and we're attacking this election season
with a lot of gratitude and
hope and excitement for what could come
right you mentioned the importance of
this election season i'm wondering what
it was like for you to
vote in this election following your
experience
well to be honest at first there was a
certain amount of anxiety involved
with it especially with the rhetoric
around absentee
voting and mail-in ballots seeing as
that i am voting in dc
and while while registered back in
georgia
but to send my ballot off and um finally
see
that it is accepted and um received and
accepted was was very gratifying and
uh kind of relieving emotion um and that
i did my part that my voice was heard
i'm looking forward to seeing what the
rest of american voices um
what what their message is tonight and i
hope is one that can be hopeful going
forward
and in your previous interview with us
you talked about the
impact of hearing the president talk
about his handling of covet 19 and press
conferences
i'm wondering how that transitioned for
you when the president himself
was uh infected with coven 19. what was
that like
and what was your reaction to that news
it was it was no less frustrating i
think
especially seeing i felt that his quick
recovery at the
at the hands of the best doctors and
equipment that the
nation has the offer or maybe the world
um
lent itself to the sort of rhetoric that
he's been
kind of insisting on that the virus is
no more than
a sort of common flu that you can white
knuckle and get better
and i know better my family knows
as well as an unfortunate amount of
americans how
untrue that is um and especially
particularly the
the publicity stunt outside of the
hospital in which he endangered
um the lives of unless unnecessarily
endangered the lives of several around
him for the sake of
um yeah a
campaign moment um it was was really
really heartbreaking and frustrating
and tone deaf uh a moment for us as a as
a family to see
and i'm wondering how you think uh coven
19
as a whole will impact voters across the
country heading into the ballot box
today
not only um for those who were directly
impacted by it like yourself but
for other voters who have different
experiences be that economic or
or any of the other effects of this
virus
yeah i think that um if you know you can
look no further than this
administration's handling of
the pandemic and to see the
ineptitude at every level and
it should be convicting and i hope that
um
we as americans will
respond accordingly tonight um and today
you know with early voting and today at
the ballot box and i'm looking forward
to seeing the results
and grant final question for you what do
you hope the winner of this election
does to focus on coven 19 survivors
well i hope more than anything i think
that i would i would love
for um the the winner of this election
to approach the general dialogue the
in particular the victims and their
families with um
with empathy first and i don't know that
we've been getting that message
it's been a lot of excuses and
deflection
but i think empathy would is is key and
especially in something that has been as
as painful and um destructive as this
pandemic has been for so many americans
and i i hope that um they will take
responsibility that this
whoever wins for for their actions and
their response and
that they will heed the word of
experts of scientists that we can stick
to those recommendations and
limit unnecessary deaths and
and and damage to our economy and our
and
our lives grant thank you so much for
making time to join us this evening and
hope that you and your family continue
to be well we really appreciate your
time
i want to take our viewers back to some
of these
numbers that are coming in right now
again we are
going to be hearing from the pivotal
swing state arizona in the next hour or
so
it's still a bit too early to tell how
florida
north carolina and georgia are shaking
out but florida is at 93
right now with trump up by three points
and biden is showing initial strength
in north carolina again we are really
waiting on these pivotal swing states
like michigan pennsylvania and wisconsin
to know how the electoral college will
shake out for
either candidate trump went into
election day hoping for a surge of
in-person voters biden is hoping that
the mail-in votes will land in his favor
as over a hundred million people voted
early heading
into election day today i want to
transition to some audience questions we
got in over social media in the past 24
hours thank you to all of you watching
who sent in
your fantastic questions uh while we're
chatting together here
i'll be looking at the comments and if
you submit any questions i will make as
much time as i can for those so feel
free to comment
with any questions you've had about
election night
so far uh one big question we got was
about
polling which got a lot of bad pr in
2016.
uh but looking at the 2020 numbers
surrounding polling we're actually
seeing that pollsters made
a lot of important changes to address
concerns of voters around the 2016
polling
pollsters are waiting
non-college-educated voters at a lot
higher rate
heading into this election which should
really help
um the election results uh match
that of of um what pollsters are seeing
we are also getting a lot of questions
right now
about how long the results will take
your guess is certainly as good as mine
it's pretty unclear but if either
candidate wins
an unexpected state with a lot of
electoral results
um we will get more information
on that and it's looking like we might
be having some technical difficulties
uh but i'm hearing from my producer that
actually we can keep going thank you so
much
uh so i want to continue to some
additional audience questions that we're
getting in
one that i'm seeing a lot in the
comments here is about
this idea of a red mirage so this is
really important because a lot of people
voted in person today and those people
who voted in person are more likely to
be
republican voters um and that's because
of a lot of reasons one is that trump
has
had a lot of rhetoric about fraudulent
mail-in voting he's also
talked about the coronavirus not being
something to be afraid of
so we're seeing a lot of early data that
in-person voters are going to lean more
republican now the question is whether
biden is going to be able to win
over those mail-in votes again we saw
record-breaking mail-in votes over 100
million people voted
before election day in states like texas
uh voters already surpassed the 2016
voting numbers before we even got to
november third so that was a huge amount
of voter turnout
but we're just going to have to see in
sweden states like pennsylvania that
can't start processing mail-in ballots
it may appear that president trump is
ahead in the polls because
of those numbers from in-person voting
today it could seem like trump is
winning until those mail-in ballots get
counted because
again in pennsylvania votes cannot be
counted
until today another big question we're
getting is could trump refuse to leave
office it's unlikely that trump would
flat out refuse to leave office it's
more likely that he will contest
election results in some of those
battleground states
like pennsylvania we've seen him kind of
lay the groundwork for this in his
rallies over the past week he's talked
about
how it will be fraudulent if
he does not win states like pennsylvania
michigan and wisconsin
and again we're seeing him sort of lay
the groundwork for this
reasoning that he could use to
contest the election results many
strategists believe
trump will say the election was rigged
or fraudulent without conceding
if the outcome is not in his favor
and another question that i'm seeing
come in here as i'm looking at your
comments
is uh could either candidate declare
victory prematurely um yes that is
something that could happen
there is precedent for this a bit uh
looking back on bush v
gore in 2000 um some strategists
say that when bush declared victory in
2000 that made
the battle against gore a bit easier
because gore was
sort of fighting this narrative that
bush put forward of him being the winner
and he created that perception of him
being the winner so trump or
biden could repeat this method and we
saw buddha judge and sanders repeating
this method when
um the iowa caucus results were unclear
earlier on in the primary
so this is something that democratic and
republican strategists
both are focusing on heading into
tonight's election
for those of you watching thank you so
much we'll continue to update you
throughout the night on
the election results as they come in and
keep following quick take for more
information thank you so much
[Music]
oh